then you need some things to transport
data between places right so that's what
cables and backbones are around okay so
in each case I'm looking at number one
their role within a network number two
how they actually have these things our
confidence that goal okay so very simply
what's the role why do we have cables in
a network why do we need cables not
worrying about wireless stuff yeah we'll
get to that simple question why do we
need cables
why does a city need roads don't to
connect things together right so to
provide connections in this case
physical connections right okay now
cables are there's all different kinds
of cable and I'm actually going to spend
a whole lesson talking about the
different kinds and later on but
backbones all they are are a specific
kind of cable all right where's your
backbone it's here right push it put
your hand on it right now
and just feel it okay now tell me why
right now you can probably feel all the
bones it's not like that right why are
you so many bones there is anyone know
what the bones are for
their flexibility that's true however I
would suggest that burns are actually
the least flexible structure that our
body has are the the bones in your
backbone
they are flexible because they are
arranged in vertebrae right but why do
we have to have bones there at all I
mean it'd be pretty flexible without the
bones right so what why what about what
side the background the but the
backwards actually wrapped around
something
it's your spine right so your backbone
and your spine are kind of in our bodies
that kind of synonymous right what's the
function of your spine here's the here's
the analogy that was given to me a long
time ago and it's helped me a lot you
aspired okay it's kind of like the
information superhighway of your body
what's a superhighway it's like a normal
road like a normal road just like a back
road is like a normal cable but when you
walk when you drive onto a highway what
are the differences kind of differences
are there between them a normal Road in
a highway or s you buy with said he can
Tulse you're gonna you gotta pay if
you're a man okay how about say the info
in flows free now okay and it's still a
highway what's different it's much
bigger right this idea of a highway is
that it goes over other stuff so traffic
can go along very quickly the words or
the words why do the lanes there are
more of them well I kind of think so the
idea is that your spine your backbone is
a highway okay they're designed to do
the same thing as a regular road or a
regular cable but to do lots and lots
and lots of it okay the point being you
know highways connect things where
there's going to be lots and lots of
traffic okay so the same way back bones
back bones connect nodes that have more
they're going to expect to communicate a
lot
setup let's give an example
I don't know what you guys live which is
probably a good thing but I assume most
of you live in like sort of suburban
areas maybe a few of you live on some
like main roads of the unit or
townhouses that are close to them but
mostly I think about the street you live
on how many lanes does it have to - if
you've got a smaller in that mine you
got like you don't even really have two
lanes it's not like one and a half-ish
and so like there's not even a barking
down the middle okay now the idea is
that the roads that we live on they're
quite small because not a lot of traffic
goes on them okay if you put if you got
rid of the road in front of my house I
put like a you know a six-lane
superhighway there no one would use it
okay cuz there isn't that much traffic
that goes on it right however if you
think I'd say well a city like say
Sydney versus a city like Melbourne is a
really huge highway that goes between
the two of them why not a rhetorical
method
why do we build such big highways why
not just put like a dirt track there or
place like out the front of my house is
like a one and a half late why don't I
think about the Haab bridge why is the
Harbour Bridge like six or eight lanes
across plus the rail why why Suzie me
because it's going to be lots of people
there right if you made it narrower you
would experience what we call a
bottleneck
what's a bottleneck in a bottle right
lists bottlenecks are quite narrow right
and I suppose that so you can control
the rate at which you pour it because if
it was like super wired you'd be like
pouring it trying to get a little bit
barbecue so often to be like splat right
so bottle breaks are designed to be
small to limit the amount of things that
can come out of it at any given time
right but when you've got traffic or
data you know what bottlings bottlenecks
are dangerous right because there's
going to be lots of collisions and
things which took a long time to get
through okay so backbones I just like
cables by they're bigger they can
transfer more data they can transmit
faster okay